canadians are some of the nicest most
agreeable most accommodating people on
the planet
but apparently even america's hat has
its limits specifically canada's
truckers thousands of whom have
descended on the nation's capital to
protest the country's vaccine mandate
and general descent into a biomedical
police state
what a moment in canadian history
here at parliament hill
i love you canada
four decades the international left has
enjoined the workers of the world to
unite
and now that they are uniting leftist
leaders are terrified
furious
and have even gone into hiding i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from andy tanner
who says neil young keep on rocking in a
free world
also neil young papers please
show me your papers or else and shut up
that joe rogan yep that's true that's
right
it's because
the word free
means different things to different
people that's why we're all arguing over
what does this word free
mean
the libs think that freedom
means the ability to shoot up whatever
drugs you want and have sex with whoever
you want and get free stuff from the
government
the uh
sort of
libertarians
kind of agree with that they don't agree
with the free stuff from the government
part but they agree with to do whatever
you want part and then the conservatives
believe that freedom means the freedom
from sin from vice from degeneracy from
your basest appetites freedom to have a
good community and the freedom to have
safety in your neighborhood the freedom
to have flourishing families and a good
life
what does free mean
something tells me neil young's
definition is not
not the whole story
you know
neil young wrote a famous song called
old man
where he was going out and he bought a
ranch and he met this old man who had
been living on the ranch he's old man
take a look at my life and that's the
whole about buying this ranch well when
you want
meat from some of the best ranches in
america you really got to check out good
ranchers i really hate being lied to i'm
sure you hate being lied to as well and
did you know that when you go to the
grocery store and you buy your meat
you very often see a sticker that says
product of usa did you know that 85 of
the grass-fed beef in the united states
is imported from overseas
did you know that that product of usa
sticker means basically nothing as long
as there's minimal processing here you
can be importing cheap beef from from
foreign countries and they'll call it
american beef don't do it don't don't
buy that cheap imported beef that lacks
true good american flavor check out good
ranchers
all their steaks are usda prime and
choice grated means the steakhouse can
come to your door i had some delicious
rib eyes
not last night two nights ago from from
good ranches they were absolutely
fabulous grilled them up to perfection
right now you can save this is not a
joke
thirty dollars with my code knowles
canada wles at checkout 30 that's a lot
of money off any box biggest discount
they've ever offered today is the day to
save big on your new favorite steak they
are the exclusive meat company of the
daily wire for good reason go to
goodranchers.com knowles to save 30
bucks make 2022 your most flavorful year
yet good ranchers american meat
delivered the canadians are really
stepping up
this is also related to neil young so
neil young a canadian is trying to
destroy american broadcasting trying to
take down any non-woke broadcaster up it
too and including joe rogan
but then you've got these other
canadians stepping up and saying no we
don't want to live in a biomedical
security state you got thousands of
truckers
just driving through the streets of the
capitol
now coming to the u.s border to block up
the u.s border and say no we're not
going to take it anymore
you're not going to shut down our
churches you're not going to destroy our
communities you're not going to take
away all of our rights we're not going
to do it we're going to push back
truckers
the lifeblood of the economy
the the workers of the the salt of the
earth the blue collar of the blue collar
are uniting and they're they're exerting
their political
influence and power just like the left
has been begging them to do
for over a century now and what are the
leftist leaders doing in response are
they applauding are they cheering are
they supporting the truckers no the
leftist prime minister of canada justin
trudeau has gone into hiding not only
has he not shown up for the protest he's
run away he doesn't he doesn't want to
have to face the mob
the relatively peaceful mob of truckers
the relatively peaceful protest
and
and so he's gone into hiding he's issued
a statement and he's condemned the
protest
i have attended protests and rallies in
the past
when i agreed with the goals when i
supported the people
expressing their concerns and their
issues black lives matter is an
excellent example of that
but i have also chosen to not go
anywhere near protests that have
expressed hateful rhetoric
violence towards fellow citizens
and a disrespect uh not just of science
but of uh the frontline health workers
and quite frankly the 90 of truckers who
have
been doing the right thing to keep
canadians safe to put food on our tables
canadians know where i stand this is a
moment for responsible leaders to think
carefully
about where they stand
i i do not support
i do i don't do a very good canadian
accent the only one that i do somewhat
well is jordan peterson but that's not
not the same one as justin trudeau
he says i do not support
violence
i do not support hateful rhetoric
i love blm
because they would never get violent
right they would never burn a country
down for eight months
they would never spew just bile they
would never tear down a country's
revered figures and statues
and firebomb buildings and attack
federal courthouses and kill dozens of
people they would never do that not blm
that's why i support blm
but some nice generally polite canadian
truckers them i cannot support what
trudeau is
showing us is something really basic
about the way politics operates
us versus them
in politics in all
successful political movements
you've got to unite you've got to have a
team and you've got to support your team
and you've got to show grace to your
team members and you've got to
oppose your opponents this seems basic
right
but we've we've kind of forgotten that
sometimes this is why
conservatives constantly decry double
standards we say hold on that leftist
media outlet is going softer on the
leftist political activists than on the
conservative political activists
right because they're on the same team
and and the conservatives are on the
opposite team which is why they're this
isn't rocket science guys this is
politics 101
and so what you're seeing in canada now
is the the leftist media also in america
the leftist media
we're saying that these truckers are
nazis they're hateful they're violent
they're dangerous they're all sorts of
things and how do they do it well
because they they find
one guy one fringe guy doing something
bad or holding up a symbol that they
don't like or you know that's some
terrible far-right extremist evil symbol
and they'll say okay this
fringe person is representative of the
whole canadian trucker movement as far
as i can tell the canadian truckers
haven't killed anybody have they blm
killed dozens of people the canadian
truckers i don't think they've done that
and yet the bl the canadian truckers
rather are hateful terrible terrorists
they're dangerous and the blm are mostly
peaceful protests right well sure that's
a double standard why is it a double
standard justin trudeau just told you
yes well i'm going to support leftists
and i'm going to oppose conservatives
oh okay i guess we should have known
that maybe we should
maybe we should order our political
movements accordingly it's not just
happening in canada
the leftist media in america
is is coming out strongly against the
truckers and they're saying that the
truckers and anyone protesting for a
return to normal life
and freedoms and civil liberties and
good communities in canada
they're basically members of a cult
so over the weekend thousands of
protesters brought uh the capital of
canada to a standstill
dozens of trucks and other vehicles
could be seen blocking the downtown area
of ottawa as protesters rallied against
vaccine mandates masks and lockdowns
that seems
like an interesting way to spend your
weekend the demonstrations were
initially aimed at pushback against
vaccine mandates for truck drivers
crossing the u.s canada border but the
movement escalated into an expression of
disapproval with the canadian
government's covet 19 policies officials
say several investigations are underway
into reports of severe vandalism and
criminal behavior including the
desecration of national monuments where
were these protests when people were
required to take to get five vaccines to
start school where were these protests
when people were required to give their
children five vaccines they were in the
doctor's office getting vaccines they
were in the doctor's office getting
vaccinated they were making fun of left
wingers on the west coast coming up
a
cult yes it is it's a cult
these people
these truckers who are not blindly
following authority
are in a cult
these truckers who are thinking for
themselves and doing their own research
and questioning the ever-changing
proclamations of the priests of public
health
who won't just go along like good little
sheep they're in a cult
where were they when they were told to
get other vaccines
i don't know they were probably weighing
the risks and looking into the history
of the vaccines and recognizing that
certain vaccines have decades and
decades and decades of data behind them
and certain vaccines do what vaccines
are supposed to do and prevent you from
from contracting and spreading certain
diseases and viruses and then some newer
vaccines use completely new basically
untested technology with no long-term
data that don't do the things that the
public health geniuses told us they
would do and maybe they're making
prudential judgments
based on that maybe they're using their
faculties of reason and not just
following the high cult leader dr fauci
maybe that's what they're doing it's a
cult and did you did you hear what mika
said oh this was bad i almost a tear
almost dropped from my eye she said that
some of these truckers there are reports
we don't have any evidence of it so
probably didn't happen but there are
reports
that they were
desecrating
national monuments
could you imagine just imagine
if a leftist movement
ever desecrated national monuments could
you imagine if there were a leftist
movement
that existed almost entirely to
desecrate national monuments and tear
down statues and vandalize statues for
months and months oh right that exists
it's called blm and you people applauded
it
you love you love desecrating national
monuments when it's
when it's your guys doing it and when
it's monuments that you don't like
it's just it's just us versus them
that's what this is
it's just you like it when your friends
do it you don't like it when your
enemies do it so it raises this question
who is us
and who is them in this situation
we were told for many years that
the us of conservatives or the
plutocrats and the big fat cats and rich
uncle pennybags and all those
zillionaires in the corporate class and
the them the leftists they're the
workers of the world they're the salt of
the earth they're the their labor
but that doesn't seem to be the case the
truckers are a great example here
because the truckers are the lifeblood
of an economy and mika and joe sipping
their chablis from a high tower in
rockefeller plaza they're not exactly
the the teamsters are they what you're
seeing here is an historic opportunity
for conservatives
to be the party of labor to be the party
of the working class that's happening
now it's there it's it's
up for us the left has completely
abandoned these people will the
conservatives step in to fill that gap
we should it's the right thing to do and
politically it would be very smart
now
we have the opportunity as conservatives
to
be the party of the working class to be
the party of the ordinary citizen
to be the party not of the
global cosmopolitan
laptop class elite
who don't really mind lockdowns because
lockdowns don't really affect them and
who don't really have any respect for
national borders and who don't really
have any respect for national traditions
right we're that's the democrats that's
the left that's not us
we can be the
party of the traditional way of life and
good old common sense and prudence if we
seize that opportunity the libs are
making it very easy for us
gavin newsom
gavin newsom
governor of california just showed up to
the la rams game
in la
la which has an indoor mask mandate
for
big events
he goes to the game and what happens
he takes a photo with magic johnson
neither of whom are wearing masks there
are other photos of gavin newsom from
this event he's sitting he's chatting
he's having a good time he's not wearing
his mask
he gets this photo with magic johnson
which is even crazier because magic
johnson you will know
has
aids he's had aids for decades he is
immuno he is as immunocompromised as
they get
and yet magic johnson's not cowering in
fear with the mask gavin newsom's not
cowering in fear with the mask this
photo was taken other photos were taken
gavin newsom tried to explain it away
i was very judicious yesterday
very judicious and you'll see the photo
that i did take
where
magic was kind enough generous enough to
ask me for a photograph and in my left
hand's the mask and i took a photo uh
rest the time i wore it uh as we all
should
not when i had a glass of water or
anything and i encourage everybody else
to do so and uh
and that's it
and that's it it's just look we just
took this photo okay and it was uh
we just we just and it's fine it's not a
big deal except there are other videos
there are videos of them walking up
hugging it's not just that briefly you
take the mask down in between sips in
between bites take a quick photo no they
weren't wearing their masks
and magic i should say magic johnson has
hiv he doesn't have full blown aids he
has he has hiv
pretty immunocompromised
okay it's quite immunocompromised
that's the word that was the word of
2020. immunocompromised no one had ever
used that word before now everybody uses
that word
except the the most immunocompromised
people
not not so worried about it what's that
about
i am beginning to think
that what most protects people
from covid19
is not
masks again i'm not making a medical
claim about masks or vaccines or
whatever please youtube don't please
youtube don't take me down okay
i'm just saying what most protects
people from covid19 it's not the masks
and it's not the vaccines
i think what it is is
money and power
because there's this just an observation
i've made
really rich
really powerful people
they don't follow any of the public
health measures that they encourage
other people to follow
i'm thinking of people like the mayor of
san francisco i'm thinking of people
like the mayor of new york i'm thinking
of people like joe biden i'm thinking
people like dr fauci i'm thinking of
all of these people
they don't but they're the one thing
they have in common is they're really
rich and they're really powerful
and they want you to live according to a
set of rules that they themselves
will not
follow
i guess we all just need to become
really rich and powerful and then we
won't catch covet either
or maybe there's something else going on
maybe
a lot of this covid regime that we're
living under
is not so much about the virus and it's
not so much about the health and the
cough and the chills
maybe it's a little bit more about
reshaping the political order you know
speaking of money and power
there is one name that you're not
allowed to say in politics do you know
his name that is
with george soros
you're going to talk about you might be
kicked off of social media i you're not
allowed to say george soros because if
you mention the name george soros
you are
an anti-semitic conspiracy theorist if
you just even say the name
because some conservatives have
previously observed that george soros
is a huge funder of very far left-wing
causes and a huge funder of democrat
politicians and that he's exerting a lot
of his influence to destroy our country
but you see george soros is jewish
and so if you
ever mention that you're an anti-semite
and you're a conspiracy theorist too
because i guess george soros doesn't
really give any money it's a total
boogie man it doesn't oh wait a second
we've got
we've got federal
documents here from the election
commission showing
that george soros
has donated just year to date just to
one super pac
125 million dollars
that's
that's a lot of money 125 million
dollars i'm seeing it just year to day
just to one super pack
for
to promote left-wing causes
but i thought that was a racist
conspiracy theory i am now pretty
convinced
that when the liberal establishment
calls something a racist conspiracy
theory
you can be almost certain almost not 100
but almost certain
that that observation is true
because racist
for the left racist doesn't really mean
racist well they've changed the
definition of racist the anti-defamation
league changed the definition just
within the past
few weeks
from
hating people based on their race to
only something that white people can do
against non-white people so they change
the definition frequently but it really
doesn't even have that much to do with
race racism
what racism means in the modern leftist
parlance is
bad
just bad if you're a racist if i say
you're a racist all that means is you're
bad
really all it means is i don't like you
because the left doesn't even
generally believe in objective truth
they just believe that politics is a
system of interests we're all just
trying to club each other on the head
and there's no logic or transcendent
moral order so it just means i don't
like you
okay so that's what racism and then
conspiracy theory
in modern leftist parlance means
something that will be proven true in
nine months
so
something i don't like that will be
proven true in nine months is
is what they're talking about and that
would seem to be the case
when we're talking about the influence
of someone like george soros when we're
talking about
the origins of covid when we're talking
about the effectiveness of mitigation
measures when we're talking about on and
on
and on and on
but that's a lot of power
125 million bucks from just one guy just
here today to just one super pac that's
a lot of power
and this is the left exerting this power
through all of the institutions and they
are all coming down right now on one man
on one pot smoking
dmt
chomping i don't really know how you
take dmt
wrestling ufc
watching
broadcaster named
joe rogan joe rogan is
persona non grata he is public enemy
number one for the left
because he is giving a big platform to
dissenting opinions
neil young tried to get him canceled
joni mitchell tried to get him canceled
a bunch of other even less well-known
musicians tried to get him canceled
hasn't quite worked but
now he's feeling the pressure and joe
sort of
back backtracked a little bit
the problem i have with the term
misinformation especially today is that
many of the things that we thought of as
misinformation just a short while ago
are now accepted as fact like for
instance eight months ago if you said if
you get vaccinated you can still catch
covid and you can still spread covid
you'd be removed from social media they
would they would ban you from certain
platforms
now that's accepted as fact if you said
i don't think cloth masks work you would
be banned from social media now that's
openly repeatedly stated on cnn all of
those theories that at one point time
were banned were openly discussed by
those two men that i had on my podcast
that have been accused of dangerous
misinformation one of the things that
spotify wants to do that i agree with is
that at the beginning of these
controversial podcasts like specifically
ones about kovid is to put a disclaimer
and say that you should speak with your
physician and that these people and the
opinions that they express
are contrary to the opinions of uh the
consensus of experts which i think is
very important i'm sure have that on
there i'm very happy with that um also i
think
uh if there's anything that i've done
that i could do better is uh have more
experts with differing opinions right
after i have the controversial ones uh i
would most certainly be open to doing
that
it's unfortunate that joe is in this
position i can't even imagine the
pressure he's getting i'm not gonna pile
on him for this backtrack i think this
backtrack
depending on what happens now this
actually could be tactically pretty
smart it's too bad that he gave in on
the disclaimer he probably shouldn't
have done that or if he did he should
have had disclaimers on the other shows
presenting the liberal viewpoint on
kovid too
but
depending on what happens now this could
either be the smartest thing the man's
ever done or the dumbest thing the man's
ever done don't forget joe rogan's
genius his magic power
is that he's talking to a huge swath of
americans not just right-wing
conservatives probably not even all that
many relatively right-wing conservatives
a lot of people in the middle a lot of
people on the left the guy was a bernie
bro if he can
bring them over if he can expose them to
thought that is contrary to the leftist
orthodoxy that's great and and the way
he's going to do that is he's going to
have to maintain his platform calm
everyone down and that's kind of what
he's doing you're saying look guys look
uh everything that my guys said on this
show was totally right and they're
extremely credentialed and they're great
and they're awesome but sure maybe we'll
bring some balance i'm the balanced guy
don't worry it's all good hey let's calm
down be cool keep calm and carry on
could be actually a pretty brilliant way
to handle it
when you're feeling calm when you're
feeling cool when you want to kick back
a little bit i would strongly recommend
you check out helix would you like to
sleep in my bed
maybe you do
i don't know probably though you
wouldn't want to do it every single
night you want to sleep in your bed you
want to sleep in a bed built for you and
with helix you can do that helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete and matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep so if
you're looking for a mattress take that
quiz order the mattress you're matched
to it comes right to your door shipped
for free you don't ever need to go to
that mattress store again which is great
they've got a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
love it helix has financing options
flexible payment plans so it's a great
night's sleep that is so so close it is
within your reach helix is offering up
to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com knowles that's helix
sleep.com
knowles for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
also tonight 9 p.m eastern 8 pm central
candace owens sits down with dr robert
malone in an exclusive two-part
interview airing tonight and tomorrow
neil young is going to be furious about
this i want that canvas cancelled i'm
pulling my music from from the daily
wire i didn't kneel we don't have your
i'm doing it don't don't you stop so
after all hell broke loose with the dr
malone interview on rogan candace
decided that she wanted to make sure
that all voices are heard take a listen
in order to evaluate any vaccine you
want to hear both sides of an argument
all media and information that we are
currently encountering is manipulated i
want to jump in and talk about when your
interview with joe rogan started going
viral not only was google triggered a
whole range of of legacy media work
triggered it's an entire ecosystem of
illegality and corruption you should be
and you are appropriately outraged about
this you can judge the value of society
by how it treats its children our
treatment of our children has been
atrocious this is the red line right
this is the line what is it that drives
you to keep going toward truth i've been
given the gift that i might be able to
make a positive impact how can i walk
away from it
[Music]
you can watch both parts of this
interview exclusively at dailywire.com
part 1 airs tonight at 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central and part 2 will premiere
tomorrow at the same time if you don't
already have a daily wire membership
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
right now use code science for 25 off
you're not going to want to miss this
code science we'll be right back with a
lot more
welcome back to the show
joe rogan is going to keep calm and
carry on do you know who can't keep khan
our president our president is having
huge mood swings
he's mumbling to himself rambling
incoherently and then he'll just start
shouting really and he'll he'll do this
thing come on man so joe uh joe biden
not joe rogan joe biden was just giving
a speech up in pennsylvania about
infrastructure and out of nowhere he
starts screaming at the crowd
imagine being the parent
making the minimum wage or twice the
minimum wage
and having a child with type 1 diabetes
knowing that if you can't and have no
insurance
knowing if you cannot get
that money for the insulin the child
might die
in addition to your child
it strips you of your dignity damn it
can you imagine looking at your child
and you know
what they need
and not be able to do it
many of you have lost children
many of you have seen
imagine
it's outrageous
what is he talking about what does this
have to do with infrastructure what this
isn't working
i'm not just saying that because i don't
like joe biden and i'm on the other side
of the political aisle look at any of
the polls none of this is working the
guy's poll numbers are completely
collapsing he's below water on every
single issue
this isn't working
why in part
it's because joe biden is too old
it's he's too yes the thing he's
describing is bad although it's kind of
weird the way he described it he said he
was calm for the part about and your
child might die
but then he got really angry and
animated for the part about you might
you might feel undignified
hold on you're trying if you're gonna
get angry about anything get angry about
your child is gonna die not about anyway
it's because he's losing his political
touch and the reason this isn't working
is because joe has been around forever
so the problems that he's describing are
problems that he probably should have
tried to fix sometime in his 50-plus
year political career at the national
level of politics
when he was vice president of the united
states
when he was a senior senator for so long
why didn't he fix any of this then
you ca you can't be the outsider saying
look at how terrible everything is buddy
you've been running the country for half
a century you've played a significant
role in running the country for half a
century so if everything's still screwed
up that's on you
that's you're
you you've been there you've been in
that place remember when joe biden
and barack obama were supposed to fix
america's health care system they were
going to pass obamacare and all the
health care problems were going to go
away and joe biden at the at the signing
ceremony for obamacare was caught on a
hot mic saying this is a big f in deal
this is a big well if it was such a big
f in deal how come all the same problems
still exist
because your your policies failed they
didn't do the thing you're supposed to
do and so you can scream and yell at the
audience until you're blue in the face
but no one believes you anymore
because you're not you haven't done any
of the things that you've been
complaining about
it's getting much
harder
for the democrats to say
that everything's going to get a lot
worse if the republicans win that the
whole world is going to get a lot worse
if the republicans win they're trying to
do it but it just seems ludicrous
there's an msnbc contributor malcolm
nance who just claimed that if the gop
wins the house back in the mid-term
elections
then the american experiment is over
putin may have started this as a test
right to see if joe biden would fold
almost immediately you have to see
another thing putin also understands the
opportunity of having a republican
um you know giving the republicans
ammunition to topple the american
government this november and i don't say
that lightly
if the republicans win power this
november
that's it the american experiment is
over
it is the basis for autocracy they you
know they'll follow through with their
threat to make trump speaker of the
house and use that as a springboard to
make him president and then there will
never be another free or fair election
in the united states putin understands
that by giving biden this crisis he gets
the republicans like tucker carlson and
all of these other people who is acting
as a propagandist for putin
there are a lot of problems with what
malcolm nance just said first is the
historical fact that democrats have
always gone much softer on russia than
the republicans have
the democrats made up this whole thing
about colluding with the russians during
the trump administration but it was just
completely made up it was cooked up by
democrat political operatives and the
deep state it wasn't real it went
nowhere the mueller investigation or
it's mueller time remember that it went
nowhere it was completely fake
here's my evidence to you
republican president george bush
vladimir putin tries to invade
the sovereign country of georgia
bush says no
putin backs off
barack obama democrat president putin
invades crimea a region of ukraine
obama says okay well all right but now
listen vlad don't go any further no no
come on now all right and so vladimir
putin keeps crimea
the democrat allowed putin to conquer
part of his neighbor
then donald trump
vladimir putin he didn't just stop
wanting land all around the world he
just didn't invade countries anymore
because he knew that trump would blow
him to smithereens
then joe biden comes in what happens
vladimir putin is planning an invasion
of
ukraine and is it is already sort of
underway on the ukrainian border
so which party is weaker on russia
the republicans who don't let putin
invade his neighbors or the democrats
who always let putin invade his
neighbors obviously the latter but then
consider the ridiculous point he's
making for domestic politics
malcolm nance from msnbc
he says
he says if the opposition party ever
wins any election
that's autocracy
so if the if the current ruling party
never loses elections ever again that's
democracy
and if the people can elect a different
party that's
autocracy
that of course would be the opposite
of reality but this is what they believe
i don't even think he's being
disingenuous here because when they say
democracy they don't really mean
democracy they mean liberalism they mean
progressivism they mean leftism but they
don't mean democracy
this is why
when
conservative
candidates win elections in the united
states in poland in hungary in brazil
wherever
that's always a threat to democracy and
you'll see it on the headlines
conservative candidate wins in poland
polish democracy under threat the new
york times were just writing about that
polish democracy is under threat because
the people elected a non-liberal
so democracy well if the people elected
him
by definition that is democratic
but liberalism is generally quite
anti-democratic and progressivism is
very anti-democratic because they
believe that there is a science of
history a science of politics that they
can know basically with certainty
and so they're going to progress to that
point and if you stand in the way of
that
then that's a big problem and so what
they're going to do is create a lot of
anti-democratic institutions like the
administrative state like various
technocratic czars and they're going to
run our lives for us dr fauci is going
to run our lives for us and he's going
to make our life much more progressive
and much more left-wing
and much more liberal
and not very democratic but that's fine
because he knows what's best
the opposite of reality you want to talk
about autocracy and democracy
and conspiracy theories pennsylvania
court pennsylvania state court just
admitted
something that
conservatives knew for a very long time
namely the democrats cheated in the 2020
election in pennsylvania they cheated
it's plain as day
the state constitution in pennsylvania
says you can't have widespread mail-in
ballots the democrats passed a law
anyway saying you're going to have
widespread mail-in ballots
this was challenged
it was allowed to stand during the
election because of kovid because of the
emergency you can violate the
constitution
then joe biden got 50 bazillion votes or
whatever in pennsylvania the most votes
ever of any person in the history of
voting and then the state court admits
oh wait a second it actually is
unconstitutional
new york times writing about this i love
the way the new york times
writes about this
pennsylvania courts says state's mail
voting law is unconstitutional
first line this is the very first
sentence of the article a state court in
pennsylvania on friday struck down the
state's landmark election law is
unconstitutional dealing a temporary
blow
to voting access in one of the nation's
most critical battleground states
a temporary blow what do you mean a
temporary blow the court said it's
unconstitutional
yeah but don't worry we'll get around
the court
yeah whatever court schmort
yeah it's temp don't worry we're gonna
get what we want constitution be damned
they're admit it's so brazen
it's so confident it's so bold to say
yeah whatever that idiot judge said it's
temporary we'll fix it
don't worry we'll get to we're going to
run these elections
however we want and you can hold up my
constitution and that's great good for
you
but we've got the power
we've got the vision we've got the zeal
and we're going to do it
that's what they're saying
so anti-democratic so offensive
to ordinary people so offensive to to
the pennsylvania public to the american
people who just want to have some say in
their government
this is a great opportunity for
conservatives
to to
rework
the way that our political
coalitions are set up
the the democrats are now telling us we
don't care what the people want we're
going to force them to do what what we
tell them to do and we're not even going
to follow our own rules it's as elitist
as it gets
as hypocritical as it gets
and you got the truckers
siding with the conservatives
you've got parents right now siding with
the conservatives
you've got when you look at the racial
demographics they're breaking quite
significantly for conservatives
or in the direction rather of
conservatives
so you saw a little bit of movement with
the black vote you're seeing huge
movement right now with the hispanic
vote
you're seeing big movement with the
suburban man just means white
white middle class women in the suburbs
they're breaking
in the direction of conservatives we've
got to seize this opportunity but if you
really want to seize this opportunity
you can't just recite the same stupid
platitudes of the last 20 years of
so-called conservatism you're going to
need to actually rethink things
you're not just going to hoodwink
huge demographics of people to come over
to your side if your policies will not
actually benefit them and if you're
you're
you don't really consider them to be
your base your constituency
so so this is an issue right now that
senator ron johnson is trying to work
through senator ron johnson republican
senator perfectly fine fella i'm not not
really attacking senator johnson but he
was just asked a question by a member of
the press and his answer i think
expresses
some of the soul-searching that the the
gop is going to have to do right now
specifically on the issue of family
policy
people decide to have families and and
become parents
that's something
you know they they need to consider
when they make that choice
i've never really felt it was society's
responsibility
uh to take care of other people's
children
okay so
senator johnson perhaps he can be
forgiven he is a republican who came up
in a different age
with different talking points and
different platitudes and very often
politicians are beholden to
the years they first got elected okay
but that answer is not going to work
what he's saying is the government has
no role in encouraging families that's
for culture
that's for civil society that's not
that's for the private sphere that's not
for the public sphere that's not for the
government
you know buster
government played a role in the problem
in the first place when government
signed trade deals
that gutted whole industries and whole
communities and whole classes of people
that had an effect on family policy when
the government came in
and
made divorce much easier that gutted
families
when the government came in and changed
regulations
around
contraception adoption
around the economy even
that had an effect
on
families when the government came in
and took away virtually any impediment
to mass migration in america and crushed
the wages particularly of the working
class that had an effect on family
formation it's a lot harder to raise a
family then that was government that
wasn't
the culture that wasn't the civil
society that wasn't just you know we've
got to go change hearts and minds that
was the government that did that with
laws and court decisions
and executive orders and treaties and
maybe the government needs to fix some
of those problems too
obviously
the basic role of government is do good
stuff and avoid bad stuff
that's
at the most basic level that's what
politics exists for okay and anyone who
tells you otherwise is just
putting lipstick on on a pig here or
they're trying to gussy up something
that's a plain fact we want we want more
good well i guess it's not it's not
piggish to say we want good stuff we
don't want bad stuff but that's the
basic level okay
there's a lot the government could do to
help us get out of this mess and
encourage family formation in hungary
and russia by the way they're just
paying people to have kids not the worst
idea but what else there are other
things we could do we could restrict
immigration we could encourage marriage
we could end abortion we could regulate
contraception even we could do it
there's a lot of stuff we could do okay
that would help families
and i think republicans are going to
need to start speaking seriously about
that if we want to hold on to the gains
that we are making in traditionally
left-wing demographics
speaking of family formation
i just saw the most
it was the most horrifying clip i've
ever seen on the news
i've seen a lot of ugly things on the
news but in terms of an actual just news
segment not covering an event but an
actual segment
made for a tv show this is the most
horrifying thing i think i've ever seen
a woman goes on a local news show
to debate abortion there's a pro-life
woman there and a pro-abortion woman
there and the pro-abortion woman
took an abortion drug and gave herself
an abortion live on air
are you advocating stocking up
on abortion pills in case roe versus
wade is overturned
yes so they are incredibly safe safer
than viagra or tylenol
uh
they've actually been in
medical practice since 2000 so if you
order it through the mail that would be
the same thing you would receive if you
were to walk into a clinic
and the change that recently happened is
previously
you had to actually physically go to a
doctor to receive at least the first of
the medication
and now you can get it sent to you
through the mail
on a sliding scale
and um
and it is
extremely easy and
private and allows you to really
self-manage your abortion
and charlie i just really i want to
share with you really quickly like
this this here is miss
pristone this is the first of two pills
you would take the end of pregnancy and
it wouldn't induce an abortion this very
pill
by blocking the hormone and allowing a
pregnancy to grow and i want to show you
how easy it is and safe it is by taking
it myself
we're going to cut it off there i don't
i don't actually want to show this woman
taking the pill because she's killing
someone on television and this we don't
want to have snuff videos on here so
we're not going to show that she says
it's her third abortion
i have no reason not to believe her she
says she's pregnant there i have no
reason not to believe her about that
either she seems giddy to kill her
children and you'll notice when she
holds up the pill
she's got a tattoo on her hand and that
tattoo is
of a pentagram
it's a sign of witches
i'm i'm not this is not some fevered
crazy delusional thinking this is what
witches self-described witches
use as one of their symbols it's a
satanic symbol it's an occult symbol
do you think that's just a coincidence
do you because there are people who say
okay listen you keep your religion you
keep your religion out of my politics
and my health care and then they hold up
their hand and they've got a satanic
symbol there
what about your what about your religion
well let's definitely keep your religion
i think my religion christianity is
pretty good in politics and healthcare i
think it's good because it's it's a good
rel it's true religion
and it leads to human flourishing
and i think that your religion
satanism is bad and should definitely be
suppressed we should definitely keep
that one
out of politics and health care
but they will say oh come on you silly
i'm not really a satanist come on
there's nothing there's no there are no
gods there are no deities there's no
angels or demons it's all just stuff i'm
just it's just like kind of a symbol
right a symbol of what darling why are
you wearing the symbol
this reminds me of that quote by
baudelaire the finest trick the devil
ever played was to convince people that
he does not exist
but you see it every once you see it you
can't unsee it
why is this woman why does she have a
satanic symbol on her hand why did saul
alinsky the author of rules for radicals
one of the most influential leftist
organizers and theorists of the last
hundred years
a mentor to hillary clinton why did he
acknowledge in the in the beginning of
his first edition of rules for radicals
why did he acknowledge right after the
dedication lucifer
he in part dedicated the book to lucifer
who he said was the first rebel who lost
himself heaven but one for himself a
political power a kingdom
is that just oh haha it's just a
coincidence it's just a symbol it's not
real well you know i'm seeing a lot of
this stuff
i'm seeing a lot of this symbolism and
and
or symbols are just meaningless
if if what you're saying if what the
materialists are saying is true that
there's nothing spiritual there's
nothing
beyond this physical world of matter
then symbols are meaningless right
because they don't refer to anything
but if they're meaningless why why do we
have them and why are they all kind of
the same symbol and why are they all
why are they all satanic
maybe there maybe there actually is
something there
the question that we need to ask
ourselves in public life is not should
we have religion
in politics or should we not have
religion in politics
all politics comes down to religion
there's no escaping it all human
conflict is theological you can admit it
or you cannot admit it but it's always
going to come down to that because it's
always about moral questions and it's
always about the nature of man and his
relationship to the state and so you
can't avoid it the question is not are
we going to have religion or not have
religion the question is are we going to
have true religion or false religion
which one what do you want do you want
here are two choices that this lady is
going to present to you christianity or
satanism what do you want to live under
well i
i don't know can i just have
zoroastrianism uh maybe and i don't
think so i don't think that that's not
really an option is it that's not really
what we're talking about
you can't avoid it
and it's a very childish impulse
of of people on the left and the right
to try to avoid the ultimately religious
character
of
of politics obviously what that woman
did should be illegal obviously these
drugs should be illegal you're going to
hear some people say well you can't ban
it how can you ban it it's a pill in the
mail you can order it on the internet
i don't know how do we ban other drugs
on the internet how do we order how do
we ban ordering illegal weapons on the
internet how do we ban downloading child
pornography on the internet how about
that should we well it's on the internet
well it's just it's it's too hard to
control well it's too hard to ban things
so we're i i don't know we do a pretty
good job of banning all of those other
things we arrest lots of people every
year for violating that law
maybe we can ban this too
certainly you can go after the dealers
certainly you can go after the middlemen
and the distributors certainly you can
go after the mail carriers for goodness
sakes
but you can you can we have political
power guys
we have we just have to use it
take a lesson from the truckers up in
canada we got a lot more political power
than some people think that we do we've
just got to use it i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire